this is from just the news FBI
whistleblower alleges January 6 cases
manipulated to create illusion of
natural National crisis I want to pause
real quick by saying something
we've ragged on the FBI but that's
unfair it is there is a dangerous
element within the FBI their top brass
is particularly bad and they've been
weaponized however I had some federal
agents from different uh different
entities speaking to me emailing me and
we've even had current contractors come
on the show and talk and the issue is
the culture war is everywhere even
within the FBI even within the DEA or
the doj whatever element of the DHS
many of these people are scared to speak
up and that's unfortunate but some of
these people are speaking up now and
these FBI whistleblowers are doing
they're doing the Lord's work coming out
and exposing the corruption within the
doj so this right here shows us the FBI
whistleblower coming out and exposing
what's going on not the first one it's
like the third or fourth that there are
very good people that work in law
enforcement at the federal level that
want to be stewards of the Constitution
that want to defend our rights and make
our country better there are many people
that got into that line of work for good
reasons and now they're starting to call
out the bad and that's what we need so
to all the good law enforcement officers
and FBI despite what our Anarchist
friends who come on the show might think
I think you're doing the right thing
coming out and exposing this and I think
clearly there are people who got into
this for the right reasons and now for
the right reasons they're exposing the
hypocrisy and the crime so here's the
story
the top uh the top Republican on the
house Judiciary Committee said Monday a
whistleblower has come forward detailing
how the FBI is manipulating cases
related to January 6 to create the
illusion that domestic violent extremism
is a widespread problem in the U.S yes
Jim Jordan said in a letter to the FBI
two FBI director Chris Ray that the
manipulative case File practice was
being conducted by the bureau's
Washington field office which was
instructing local FBI offices to open up
cases on their books that were in fact
simply related to the capital breach
the FBI's categorization creates the
illusion that the threats from dve are
present in jurisdictions Across the
Nation when in reality they all stem
from the same related investigation
concerning the actions at the Capitol on
January 6 which was what 800 people and
if those people were violent prosecute
them
the Republican lawmaker said the
whistleblower's description is
consistent with disclosures we have
received from other whistleblowers that
high-ranking FBI officials including a
senior wfo official are pressing front
line agents to categorize cases as dve
matters to fit a political narrative not
only this but I don't know if you guys
saw the other story
they're pulling FBI agents off child
exploitation and moving them to domestic
extremism what that's insane especially
when you see what's happening in this
country with schools and with the media
but it makes sense the Cults want to
come for your kids and the elements of
the cult that are in the FBI are still
helping them go after your kids well it
makes sense for another reason and
that's because the FBI has a long record
of protecting the people who abuse
children whether it's Larry nasler
Jeffrey Epstein and probably many more
people that we don't even know about
there was victims coming forward
children coming forward went to the FBI
said hey even in the 90s there's people
coming forward Say Hey I was abused by
Jeffrey Epstein uh you guys need to stop
him he's hurting children he hurt me FBI
ignored it for over 30 years I gotta
deal with them what's the absolutely
gymnasts Michigan State yeah and here
how's the FBI involved well the FBI knew
exactly what he was doing and
essentially decided to Aid and Abed his
actions and ignored the victims that
were coming forward once again so
there's a record of this there it
happens more than once and you know
seeing a whistleblower is you know
optimistic but but still by and large
there needs to be an entire Reckoning
when it comes to the centralized
bureaucracy that is in Washington DC
that of course is abusing its power so
this is this is you know a good sign
that we're getting some information but
but we're just getting wasn't this guy
fired I think that was the latest update
this whistleblower was was fired really
suspended
um I think I remember reading about that
yesterday I'm going to try to look up
the story see if you can see if you can
pull that out because these
whistleblowers are heroes man calling
out the weaponization and Corruption
within the doj it's got to be scary
because you're watching them abuse their
power to crush their opponents and then
you have to willfully choose to stand
against them so I have tremendous
respect to these these agents because
like I said man this was a few years ago
I actually I met a guy I can't remember
I was at a conference or something and
he worked for one of the national
security agencies who was a contractor
because they're mostly contractors and
he was explaining that he supported
Trump that he believed in the
Constitution that he was I think you
know I don't I don't want to say his
race just he was not white and and he
said it's scary because the same thing
that we describe outside of the of the
of these of netsack they have inside as
well and he's like we don't what do we
do you know they'll just fire you if you
speak out so you try and do your best to
do the right thing but I think there's a
lot of good people that are in there
because there's a lot of good people all
over this country you just got to call
it the corruption do you find it I think
Jim Jordan was speaking about this to
Tucker Carlson last night and he was
talking about this specific case you're
not in your head do you remember that I
I didn't watch but that's the that's the
article that I read yes so Jim Jordan
FBI whistleblower
um and um I think it was Jim Jordan
correct me if I'm wrong that that The
Whistleblower was found and suspended
currently suspended because it's really
hard to fire federal employees yeah so I
got to be corrected I'm speaking off off
the cuff just off of what I remembered
from last night just reading it and
passing I mean it's just outright creepy
that they're trying to fabricate this
stuff and for what you know what worries
me is that we had a couple people Super
Chat us the other day that that uh their
friends are being deployed to uh the the
Pacific in two weeks yeah and and it's
like how convenient for Joe Biden if a
war were to break out with China right
before a midterm election where they
desperately need to cling to power or
the illusion of a war I mean just as
long as people think exactly some
skirmishes some some conflict that
resolves itself in in December I mean
he's a hero in our media and XI
jinping's a hero in the Chinese media
and then they both win their elections
man I don't think this extremist stuff
is really is is nearly what what has
been provoked for it to seem by this
these certain media organizations like
it never was extreme in the 90s and 2005
and like the the after 9 11 there was
Radical Muslim extremist talk and it was
all about the Muslims and like
this weird divisive I must have earned a
lot of money for people whatever they
can do to generate hatred and propaganda
just because they want Millions yeah we
found the gym you want to go ahead yeah
no I I've just hunted down the article
again but Jordan said The Whistleblower
was suspended from his job Monday and
what the congressman called a
retaliatory firing so that's illegal
isn't it sure yeah whistleblower
protection is is something that is a
real thing and if you come forward with
information providing that the
government did something wrong you're
supposed to be protected not suspended
and fired and punished for
whistleblowing on something that
legitimately is a problem in the United
States and leading to radicalization and
leading towards a larger divide and
conquer agenda from what I see it when
reach for comment by Tucker Carlson show
the FBI said the threat posed by
domestic violent extremists is
persistent evolving and deadly that's it
didn't exist before 9 11 that's what I'm
talking about this persistent threat is
weird
I don't know if it's because they want
to raise money for the military because
they're afraid as the liberal economic
order evolves into a world order they
want to maintain martial law in the
United States so people don't Revolt
when they realize it's going to be 30
bucks for a can of Coke or whatever uh
that maybe that's why they're drumming
up such the war on terror is just
turning inwards you know we have the
radical islamists that were financed by
the CIA for so many decades you can only
do that for so long now you'd need of
course domestic extremism of course to
turn the war on Tower towards the
American people we have all the national
security surveillance State already set
up we have all the national emergency
procedures already set up and it's just
only a matter of time until again it's
going to be turned inwards it already
has in my opinion and there's going to
be some very negative bad consequences
because of this like domestic foreign
thing is also the lines been blurred
right now like you get on a Facebook
Chat which is an American company with
someone and you're talking with someone
in Canada all of a sudden now that the
FBI is involved or the CIA is involved
because it's foreign and like that and
they're supposedly masking you as the
American in but then what they do is
they ask Canada hey who was that and
Canada's like oh that was this guy it's
like we didn't do it
spy Club baby
afraid this
lot like another step in the Civil War
because this is what I've been saying
they don't have enough of the supply of
white supremacy so obviously they're
fabricating it I was re I was hearing I
forget who was talking about it earlier
today all my podcasts run together but
they're talking about how they're
fabricating cases of extremism in the
U.S so they can meet certain quotas
within the FBI which is mind-boggling
but it's exactly what I said was gonna
happen looks like a civil war because as
Luke said it is just the war on terror
brought home look at the winner of each
other huh the Whitmer thing yeah yeah
exactly like 15 informants and like four
guys or something like that I think it
was like six guys in like 12 informants
something like that yeah you had to
remember those exact numbers but there
was a lot more informants than you know
crazily crazy autistic people that went
along with the government setup that
essentially was was that case George
Bush Senior was talking about the New
World Order in like the 80s late 80s and
even though I think while he was
President he was talking about this so
do you I mean do you think that this is
like they're just anticipating a
revolution into a new global system and
they want to like have a strong domestic
military presence so that we can control
the populace when it happens trying to
understand sociopaths is not an easy
thing to do he was also a big CIA guy
but but that's beyond the story here
again it's hard to quantify and
understand exactly what they're doing
why they're doing it I think even just
explaining what they're doing to the
average person out there and breaking
the conditioning breaking the Matrix
that everyone is in Breaking the
trauma-based mind control is already an
uphill battle I don't want to go as far
as to speculate exactly why they're
doing it it the fact is they're doing it
and the first thing we need to do is be
aware of it yeah I think motives are
less important than what's actually
happening and knowing what what the
Fallout of of the current events would
be is way more important than wondering
or knowing why they're why it's
happening I mean you do ultimately want
to know why people do psychologically
but realistically if someone's proposing
a plan all really matters is what's the
plan gonna do I don't really care why
you're proposing it I mean I just I just
look at you know all the families being
torn apart because of it and and look
and what the culture war and and just
these divides and everything and that's
irreparable
it's very sad yeah we we uh I think it
was Larry Elder mentioning that he had
good friends that all of a sudden they
just they wouldn't they couldn't talk
and that he presented evidence to them
and they're like I don't want to read
the evidence I mean how do you like what
do you do is it it's irreparable I agree
well it's hard too because
you know like women Suburban women
Suburban mothers me
um you know the like where where we're a
class of people who really don't want to
talk about this stuff we don't want to
acknowledge that there's people like the
Canadian professor in in our children's
classrooms and our children's life we
don't even want to acknowledge it
teacher yeah
I mean it's it's something that we just
don't even want to discuss and it's
easier for us just to say well you know
this is it's not this is one crazy
isolated case like people want to live
in denial that is how they want to live
and then you know on on the flip side
when it's like these minor little social
justice issues they feel like they can
just toss out their opinions or you know
it'll it's like an easy one to show how
woke they are in the group of some moms
or something but
um you know I I've reached a point and
partly was because of the last show uh
that I that I did with with you guys
um I'm just I'm just kind of done
staying silent about it and instead of
trying to open up up this crazy debate
with everybody that I know my new goal
is and I like I think I'm going to try
to coin the term micro activism I'm just
going to try to just show these people
show these friends these colleagues
these neighbors of mine that they're not
uh that their way is not the only way of
thinking that not everybody's on the
same page so even if it's just like a I
don't know why you would do that even if
it's just something as minor as that I
think it's important for people to know
that they are not always going to be the
majority that they they need to know
that there's people who disagree with
their way of thinking that they just
can't go around scoring these social
justice points all the time they just
can't and and these little things that
that I that these micro activism moves I
think are very important to start doing
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there